describing the head wound professor  Simon stated that that would have been n  i quote immediately incapacitating  injury clothes coats a person sustaining  a wound of that nature would would be  almost immediately incapable of  voluntary action of any kind he or she  would probably also be immediately  unconscious the rest arrest respiratory  functions would have been compromised  substantially there was also damage to  the brain as well as substantial  fracturing of the base of the skull but  minimal blood in the airways this  suggested that the disease probably did  not breathe breathe more than a few  seconds after sustaining this wound the  shots were fired in quick succession in  my view this means that the deceased  would have been unable to shout or  scream at least not in the manner  described by those witnesses who were  adamant that they had had a woman scream  repeatedly